Ich habe Sie nicht verstanden.
Wenn ich 76 Jahre sage, dann rechnen wir mal zurück.
Das sind 20, 45, ja, 1945, 26. November.
Ja, richtig.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege 72 kg.
Was habe ich für Beschwerden?
Seit ungefähr einem Jahr fühle ich mich zunehmend schlapp.
Ich habe keine Kraft mehr.
Ich habe gemerkt, ich verliere auch ein Gewicht.
Ich kann nicht mehr so richtig essen und trinken.
Seit einem Jahr?
Ja, das ist so.
Die Symptome habe ich seit einem Jahr?
Ja.
Ich habe schon mal bei einem Arzt ein Gewicht verliebt.
Ich habe seit einem Jahr die ganze Zeit immer wieder mal bei Ärzten.
Ich habe auch 3-4 Mal im Krankenhaus gelegen.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie?
Ich habe ungefähr 20 Kilogramm in den letzten 10 Monaten abgenommen.
Hast du von diesen Beschwerden noch andere Symptome?
Nein, nur dass ich kaum Kraft habe.
Ich habe keine Kraft mehr.
Ich habe keine Lust mehr zu leben.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie?
Das ist mir egal.
Nein, ich habe keine.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie?
Nein, ich kann nicht sagen.
Mit Puls habe ich kein Problem.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie?
Wenn ich liegen habe, habe ich keine Probleme.
Aber wenn ich laufen muss, dann fällt mir das schwer.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie?
Das ist nur ganz wenig.
Mir tut dann alles weh, Luftnot verspür ich nicht.
Aber es fällt mir alles schwer.
Sie haben keine Atemnot, aber sie spielen sich Schlampe.
Ist das richtig?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Das würde ich nicht sagen, nein.
Mit Stuhl und Wasserlassen habe ich kein Problem.
Gut, Herr Kaiser.
Ich konnte die ganze Zeit immer schlafen.
Ja, den ganzen Tag.
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, dass sie 3-4 Mal im Krankenhaus gelebt haben.
Welche Labordiagnostik bei ihnen durchgeführt?
Labordiagnostik.
Labord, weiß ich nicht.
Es wurde immer wieder mal Blut abgenommen.
Und immer wieder mal etwas weggeschickt und kontrolliert.
Aber was das genau ist, kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Ich bin kein Arzt.
Okay.
Wo ist bei Ihnen eine Diagnose gestartet?
Bisher hat man nichts richtiges gefunden.
Die Ärzte wissen auch nicht so richtig, was mit mir los ist.
Okay.
Was meinen Sie mit der operativen Diagnose?
Was ist mit dem Computer-Tomografie?
Also eine Computer-Tomografie hat man bei mir gemacht,
von Brust und Bauch.
Und der Darm wurde gespiegelt, das weiß ich.
Aber das sei alles in Ordnung, hat man mir gesagt.
Ich habe ein Medikament geordnet.
Ich habe kein Medikament eingenommen.
Okay.
Sie haben 20 Kilogramm Abgenomen.
Sie fühlen sich schlapp.
Bei Ihnen wurde die City durchgeführt.
Sie haben gesagt, alles in Ordnung.
Abgesehen von dieser Beschwerden leiden Sie an wichtige Erkrankungen.
Was meinen Sie mit wichtigen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe schon seit 10 Jahren mit dem Blutdruck zu kämpfen.
Der ist manchmal sehr hoch.
Dann fällt er wieder mal runter.
Mein Arzt hat den in den letzten 2 Jahren mal einigermaßen hingekriegt.
150 zu 90 ist er mit den Medikamenten, die ich hier einnehme.
Und das ist ein sehr großer Arzt.
Ich habe das nicht zu 90 mit den Medikamenten, die ich hier einnehme.
Dann habe ich auch noch ein Diabetes,
wo ich bis vor 2 Jahren Tabletten genommen habe.
Jetzt muss ich noch Insulin spritzen.
Seit 2 Jahren leiden Sie an Diabetes?
Oder seit 2 Jahren nehmen Sie Insulin?
Ich habe nicht gut verstanden.
Ich nehme seit 2 Jahren Insulin.
Diabetes habe ich schon seit mehr als 10 Jahren.
Ich nehme 2 Blutdruck-Medikamente.
Das ist einmal Ramipril oder Ramilich.
5 Milligramm sind das 1 Morgen.
Dann habe ich noch 5 Milligramm Tablette.
1 Morgen.
Abkürzen von diesen Erkrankungen haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen.
Ich habe noch 5 Milligramm Tabletten.
Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, Herr Kaiser?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Mir ist da nichts bekannt.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Nur Schmerz, wenn mir alles weh tut.
Welche Schmerz mitnehmen Sie ein?
Belegentlich nehme ich so einen Evoprofen ein.
In welcher Dosis nehmen Sie?
Das sind 400 Milligramm Tabletten, die ich 2 am Tag nehme.
Bye Bedarf.
Herr Kaiser, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Operationen? Ja, wenn Sie mich so fragen.
Im Jugendlichen Malta hat man mir den Blinddarm rausgenommen.
Ist die Komplikationslos-Verlaufen?
Ja, das war vor 50 Jahren.
Da habe ich so eine Woche lang im Kang ausgelegen und dann war alles okay.
50 Jahre, okay.
Was heißt vollständig geimpft?
Sie meinen jetzt gegen Corona?
Ich meine gegen Kinderkrankheiten.
Gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, das habe ich irgendwann mal gemacht, als ich mich in einem Garten verletzt habe.
Kinderimpfungen, ja, das war damals üblich.
Und gegen Corona bin ich auch 2-mal geimpft.
Vor einer Woche habe ich sogar die 3. Impfung bekommen.
Ich hatte die 3. Impfung schon.
Was ist das für Ihre Allergien?
Allergien, nicht, dass ich müsste.
Wie lange haben Sie alle Lebensmittel gut?
Ist her, ja.
Problem habe ich bisher nicht gehabt.
Okay, das ist gut.
Rachen Sie, Herr Kaiser?
Nee, ich habe mal so in den Jugendlichen Jahren,
vor 50 Jahren mal vielleicht ein, 2 Jahre geraucht,
dann habe ich aber aufgehört.
Wie lange haben Sie sich das nicht gut verstanden?
Könnten Sie mir noch mal sagen?
Also, das waren 2 Jahre, 2 Jahre lang.
Ja, 2 Jahre lang insgesamt.
Und da habe ich vielleicht so in einer Woche eine Packung geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, mit Alkohol habe ich nichts ermutigt.
Ich mag kein Alkohol.
Als Ihre Ersten möchte ich wissen, ob Sie irgendwann
Drogen probiert haben.
Nein, Drogen habe ich nichts ermutigt.
Das mag ich nicht.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen
von denen, die es uns wissen sollte?
Zum Beispiel bezüglich Ihrer Beschwerden.
Sie meinen, ob in der Verwandtschaft jemand so etwas hat?
Ja, ja.
Mir ist da nichts bekannt.
Natürlich haben hier und da, welche mal mit dem Blutdruck zu kämpfen.
Der eine hatte ein Diabetes,
aber sonst andere Erkrankungen kenne ich nicht.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Nein, ich bin selber schon über 25.
Nein, die sind beide schon verstorben.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater war damals im Krieg gefallen.
Meine Mutter war alt und ist eines natürlichen Todes gestorben.
Haben Sie Geschwester, Herr Kaiser?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Sind Sie in Ruhe?
Ja, ja, ich bin schon seit mehr als 10 Jahren schon pensioniert.
Was waren Sie von Beruf?
Ich war Maschineningenieur.
Mit wem leben Sie zurzeit?
Ehten nochmal.
Leben Sie allein?
Nein, ich habe eine Frau mit der Lebenszeit zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Sind beide Kinder gesund?
Ja, das ist gut.
Okay, Herr Kaiser.
Von meiner Seite, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen geschworen.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie eine Lösung bieten können.
Dass Sie diese Probleme mal aufhören.
Herr Kaiser, ich habe keine Frage.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Das suicide Marty.
Dass der
Ich spritze Landtust zur Nacht.
Nur Landtust.
Nur Landtust zur Nacht.
Ich habe noch Tabletten.
Die Tabletten nehme ich auch noch ein, aber ich muss nachts noch Landtust spritzen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit vermehrt und durft?
Nein, würde ich nicht sagen.
Bei Maslassen müssen Sie auf die Toilette.
Ich habe aber gefragt,
dass das normal ist.
Müssten Sie nachts auf die Toilette gehen?
Nein, das muss ich nicht.
Irgendwo keine Schmerzen.
Keine Bauchschmerzen.
Wie gesagt,
das ist eine andere.
Das tut mir alles weh.
Die Arme, Beine, Muskeln, das tut mir alles weh.
Die Patientfühlung ist fix und fertig.
So ist es.
Welche Worten haben Sie dabei?
Ich habe nichts dabei.
Wie gesagt, ich lag im Krankenhaus.
Das müssen Sie meinen Hausarzt fragen.
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Ich habe nichts dabei.
Eine Frage kommt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie schon erbrochen?
Nein, es ist mir weder übel, noch muss ich abbrechen.
Haben Sie Sport?
Sport, mit 75 Jahren.
Nein, schon lange nicht mehr.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen über eine Patientin sprechen.
Sie seien für mich.
Ja, na klar.
Unser Patient ist Manfred Kaiser.
Herr Kaiser ist 76 Jahre alt.
1 Meter, 72 kg gross.
Der Patient hat sich mit einer
5-T-Handel beschlossen.
Sie haben eine Antriplosik,
eine Antriplosik,
und 20 kg Gewichtabnahme
von 20 kg in der Alp-Säne-Monatin
vergescht.
Sie haben 5-T-Handel beschlossen.
Seit der Patientin
haben sie 4-T-Handel im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Im Krankenhaus gewesen.
Geben Sie.
Okay, gewesen.
Bei der Krankenhaus-Aufenthalt
ist bei Ihnen einige Unterzuhungen
durchgeführt worden.
Aber alles war unerwartet.
Sie haben eine Antriplosik,
eine Antriplosik,
eine Antriplosik.
Geben Sie.
Die Vegetative anamnese war unaufhellig.
Der Patient,
Leide,
Zahit-Säne-Jaren,
an arterielle Hypertonie,
war unerwartet.
Wir haben eine Antriplosik,
die 5-T-Handel,
eine Antriplosik,
war unerwartet.
Es war unerwartet.
Wir haben eine Antriplosik in der
und Erhabe keine und verträglichkeit
er erhabe als Jugend svanyare lang ein
pakunk provohe gerout er trinke keine alkohol
drogun konzum vurde fernayn by der
familien anam neze
ee
arterielli ee
by den manchen mit glieden
ee arterielli pertoni und lebetes melitus
aber ee
sein muta ist
ausnatürlischen güringen
fershtorben
und sein fata
bymkrik
by derkrik
im krig gefallen
im krik gefallen
er ist er sei renna
damals
habe er als machine engineer gearbeitet
lebe mit zainer frau
habe einen zon und ein tohta
sehr gut
by the zimpia
gut
was machen wir jetzt mit ihm
was schätzen sie denn was da hat
ja so erst ee
müssen wir den patienten
körperlich untersuchen
ja
bei der körperlich untersuchen
muss ich ee
irgendwo eine ee
live liveknoten
vergrößerte liveknoten
gibt ee
und ee
ich muss auch ee
lungen abhören
herz abhören
und ee
auzer dem ich muss den baun
untersuchen
und dort fiel
ee
hepatosiplanomegali oda
aufhellig kaiten
muss ich
beurteilen
ee
und dann ee
muss ich mit ee
was machen wir
was wir machen sollen ja
ich hab keine ahnung
deswegen
sehr gut
das ist schon mal der erste schritt
manchmal auch zu sagen
dass man etwas nicht weiß
das kommt auch immer wieder mal vor
in der medizin ist nicht immer alles
klipp und klar wo man sagt
das ist es ja manchmal
tap man im dunkeln sagt man
im deutschen und sagt
ich weiß nicht was dieser mensch hat
aber wir müssen irgendwo anfangen
und der erste schritt ist
dass man erstmal die briefe
aus den kranken häusern
zusammensucht ja
was haben die gemacht
was ist bisher festgestellt
worden und was hat man mit den
menschen gemacht das hat man ihm empfohlen
jetzt haben der angerufen
und sie haben aus den
kranken häusern die briefe
zufachsen lassen
wir haben gesehen die computer
tomografie war unauffällig
es gibt keine linzknotenvergrößerungen
es gibt kein tumor
und in der darf
darf ich unterbrechen
wann wurde diese
untersucht wird geführt
das ist jetzt vor kurzem gewesen
vor vier wochen
und das müssen also
nicht nochmal wiederholen
das macht keinen sinn innerhalb von vier wochen
wenn da nichts gewesen ist
und auch die damenspiegelung
die war unauffällig gewesen
da gab es kein tumor
und auch keine blutungszeichen
und man wusste nicht was der so hat
und man hat das
als unspezifische
vielleicht auch zu psychische beschwerden
bezeichnet und den man dann wieder
in den opoth des hausarztes geschickt
und im labor
hat man gesehen
dass der vielleicht ein bisschen erhöhte weiße blutkörperchen hat
der hb-wert
ist vielleicht ein bisschen niedrig
aber sonst ist die knochenmark
funktion relativ gut gewesen
und keine entzündungszeichen
und so dass man gesagt hat
ja der wird ja ehrlich
vielleicht auch so etwas wie ein myelodysplastisches
syndrome haben
das ist aber nicht so schlimm
mit 76 jahren darf der das auch haben
und man hat ihn nach hause beschickt
so jetzt stehen wir vor dem
was würden wir jetzt bei dem machen
ja
was würden wir vorschlagen
äh
knochen
knochenmark
würde ich nicht sofort in angreifen nehmen
alles was so invasiv ist
wenn wir irgendwo eine probe rausnehmen
würde ich immer zum schluss machen
also das eintige
kann die schlucken
ich würde eine magenspiegelung noch machen
das haben die kollegen nicht gemacht
warum weiß ich nicht
wenn er Schluckstörungen angibt
sollte man eine magenspiegelung machen
und der hno-art
sollte auch mal den rachenraum inspizieren
ob da vielleicht irgendein hindernis
da ist ob dann problemdans
also der hno-art sagt
das ist alles in ordnung
er kann nichts auffälliges sehen
und der gastroenterologe
der die magenspiegelung gemacht hat
sagt die alles
völlig sauber aus
was können sie noch machen
schilddrösen
schilddrösenwerte waren ok gewesen
ok
ja
was kann man bei solchen menschen noch machen
wenn die zwar
eine normale
anatomie haben, wenn alles so weit gut aus sieht
aber
wenn der mensch sagt
er kann nicht richtig schlucken
was kann man da noch machen
gibt es nicht knochen im hals
nein, gibt es keine
man kann noch einen so genannten
esophagusbrei-schluck machen
um zu schauen
ob der esophagus
gut kontraktil ist
ob der schluckakt
gut abläuft
oder ob es da irgendwelche
ich sag mal
störungen gibt
was den ablauf irgendwie verzögert
sodass der mensch nicht richtig
wunterschlucken kann
der patient hat das auch nicht angegeben
was haben denn menschen
die ein schluckproblem haben
die haben
Regokitationen sagt man ja
sprich das was sie nicht wunterschlucken können
kommt dann abends meistens
immer retro grad hoch
also zurück in den mund das gibt er nicht an
der sagt er hat eine generelle schwäche
er kriegt nichts runtergeschluckt
das hat er eben vergessen
zu sagen
er muss immer mit flüssigkeit
mit dem schlucken
er muss alles mit flüssigkeit
runtergeschlucken
sonst bleibt alles klebend
er kriegt das nicht runter
aber der patient hat nicht davon
er ist das richtig
das hat er vergessen
er kann nicht richtig schlucken
aber wie gesagt
der Breischluck ist normal
die Gastroskopie ist normal
jetzt muss es aber irgendwie klick machen
woran müssen sie denken
die haben das nicht gelöst
das haben wir mit dem Breischluck ausgeschlossen
ja
wir haben schon ausgeschlossen
also in solchen Fallen
müsste man immer an eine
Autoimmunerkrankungen denkt
er gibt ja auch generalisiert
Schmerzen überall an
er sagt
er tut ihm alles weh
er kann nicht richtig schlucken
können sie da irgendwelche Autoimmunerkrankungen
die so etwas auslösen können.
Kann ich zu diesem Patienten und diesem Alter meine Meinung sagen?
Noch mal bitte.
Kann ich nur zu diesem Patienten, 76 Jahre Patient und diesem Alter Meinung sagen?
Gerne, klar.
Die Patienten, die sich für eine gewisse Abnahmung gibt, sind Hinweise auf einen schon länger bestehenden Instrumenten denken.
Aber nein.
Aber diese Patienten sind nicht gut symptomatisch, nur die Gewisse Abnahmung.
Alle Saberlaboren und Apparatildiagons sind normal.
Wir müssen jetzt eine autoimmunerkrankung suchen.
Der Diabetes-Problem hat er nicht.
Der HW1C ist okay.
Auch mit dem Essen hat er nicht das Problem.
Der Diabetes ist gut eingestellt.
Er hat ein ganz anderes Problem.
Er kriegt das einfach nicht runtergeschluckt.
Er hat jetzt Gewicht verloren, weil er sich nicht ausreichend ernähren konnte.
Er konnte einfach funktionell sich nicht mehr ernähren.
Jetzt geht es darum, warum er sich nicht ernähren kann.
Was ist das Problem?
Wir denken als erstes an eine Autoimmunerkrankung.
Und danach gucken Sie da, wenn Sie an eine Autoimmunerkrankung denken, was kontrollieren Sie alles so?
Lungo.
Noch mal bitte.
Lungo, vielleicht Siklore derma kann sein.
Aber bald ist es Siklore derma, wenn es andere Symptome gibt.
Eine Symptome.
Siklore derma.
Siklore derma könnte schon sein.
Aber das wäre ziemlich stark, wenn jemand mit einer Siklore derma solche generalisierte Probleme hätte.
Aber von der Schluckstörung her könnte es natürlich passen.
Das ist richtig.
Aber was noch? Man könnte alles zusammen in irgendeine Abkläre.
Man nimmt einfach die anti-nukleären Antikörper ab, die Anas.
Und dann guckt man, ist da etwas positiv, ja oder nein.
Und Sie sehen, der Täter, der Anateter, ist ein bisschen erhöht.
Das weiß ich, 1 zu 300, 1 zu 400.
Aber die einzelnen Autorantikörper, wie SCL 70,
die Sklerodämie sprechen würde, ist normal.
Und wir sehen auch sonst keine anderen Auffälligkeiten.
Boran muss man noch denken, irgendjemand hat das da eben so ein bisschen erwähnt gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er das bewusst gemacht hat oder einfach nur geraten hat.
Muskelprobleme und Autoimmunerkrankungen.
Was hängt da zusammen?
Sehr gut. Das könnte eine Möwestennie sein.
Und wie kontrollieren wir eine Möwestennie?
Antikor.
Ja, welche Antikörper?
Asetylcholine.
Ja, das sind Asetylcholine-Receptor-Antikörper.
Und all das schütten sie weg.
Also wenn sie so jemanden bekommen, wo sie nicht wissen, was da genau groß ist,
machen sie eine sehr, sehr breite Autoimmunabklärung.
Da schicken sie alles Mögliche weg.
Und ich hatte gerade so einen Patienten.
Und der war in der Gastroenterologie gewesen.
Der war in der Kardiologie gewesen.
Der lag auch in der Neurologie.
Und weil wir alle nicht wussten, was der hat, haben sie gesagt,
der muss unbedingt eine Tumorerkrankung haben.
Weshalb er zu mir in der Onkologie kam.
Und dann haben wir alle Befunde zusammengetragen.
Und das, was der Neurologe übersehen hatte, war,
er hatte eine Autoimmundiagnostik gemacht
und einen sehr hohen Asetylcholine-Receptor-Antikörper übersehen.
Ja.
Und der Mann hatte nichts anderes als eine Myosthenie.
Obwohl ich diesen Wert noch nicht hatte, habe ich gesagt,
der muss eine Autoimmunerkrankung haben.
Die Schmerzen, die Schwäche, das passt irgendwie nicht.
Der hat nichts Organisches, nichts Onkologisches.
Und ich habe den Cortison gegeben.
Und mit Cortison hat man dann gesehen, der ist jeden Tag besser geworden.
Der Mann, der nicht schlucken konnte.
Der Mann, der am Anfang nicht mal richtig reden konnte.
Der hat angefangen zu reden.
Der hat gegessen, der hat getrunken.
Der ist bis auf die Bettkante, wie der mobilisiert, sagen wir.
Und dann kam eben dieser Wert dazu.
Und jetzt kommen wir nochmal zurück auf die Erkrankung.
Wie ist denn die Therapie der Myosthenie-Erkrankung?
Bei allen Autoimmunerkrankungen.
Immunsuppresiv.
Ja, aber es gibt bei der Myosthenie
eine ganz spezifische Erkrankung und eine Generalisierung.
Operation.
Noch mal bitte.
Chemektomeil kann sein.
Ja, sehr gut.
Es gibt eine Assoziation mit dem Tymus,
das durch den Tymus irgendeine Störung da fabriziert wird.
Und man kann den Tymus rausnehmen.
Muss man aber nicht immer.
Man muss nicht immer damit zusammenhängen.
Was kann man noch machen?
Medikamentös?
Pyridostygmin.
Ja, was ist das für eine Substanz?
Was macht die?
Acetylcholinesterasehemmer.
Ja, das ist eine Cholinesterasehemmer.
Sehr gut.
Also dadurch, dass man den Abbau von Acetylcholin verhindert,
bleibt die Wirkung vom Acetylcholin länger da.
Die Autoimmunerkrankung spielt sich ja in der,
ich sage mal, in der Übertragung von Nervenbahnen
auf die Muskelrezeptoren.
Ja, spielt sich da ab.
Und wenn zu wenig Acetylcholin da ist,
dann kann die Erregung vom Nerv auf den Muskel nicht übertragen werden.
Jetzt gibt man Medikamente,
die entweder die Konzentration
von Acetylcholin hochhält
oder aber, was Sie machen können,
Sie können versuchen,
gegen die Antikörper Medikamente zu geben.
Der Antikörper werden von wem gebildet?
Vom Körper.
Das Immunsystem.
Also arbeiten Sie mit immunsupressiver.
Das kann mit Cortison sein.
Das kann auch Acetyloprien sein.
Und wenn der Mensch in einer Krise ist
und der Mann war wahrscheinlich in einer Krise,
was wir am Anfang nicht so richtig erkannt haben,
dann kann man auch eine sogenannte Plasma-Verese machen.
Sprich sämtliche Antikörper aus dem Blut herauswaschen.
Und das ist eben eine sehr,
sehr wichtige Differenzialdiagnose.
Wir denken immer, es muss immer 1 plus 1
alles zusammenpassen.
Aber es muss immer etwas,
wo man dann sagt, ich komme bei dem nicht weiter.
Wie man gesehen hat, der Neurologe kam nicht weiter,
der Gastroenterologe kam nicht weiter,
der Kardiologe kam nicht weiter.
Und der Onkologe auch nicht.
Aber alle zusammen, irgendeiner hat den richtigen Riecher gehabt,
hat einfach mal die Autorantikörper bestimmen lassen.
Und per Zufall wäre dieser Wert nicht gekommen.
Hätte ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht daran gedacht.
Ich hätte vielleicht nicht den Namen Möstinni gesagt,
aber ich hätte gesagt,
der muss eine autoimmunerkrankung haben,
weil er auf das Cortison gut angesprochen hat.
Und die Therapie der Valens, wie gesagt,
das Pyridosthikmin, oder der Handelsname
bei Möstinni, ist Mestinon, was man da gibt.
Und das wird am Tag mehrmals eingenommen.
Man muss das die Anfangs langsam dosieren
und dann in den Folgetagen langsam steigern,
bis man eine gewisse Sättigungsdosis hat.
Und das muss man abhängig davon machen,
wie es den Patienten geht.
Manchmal muss man auch Cortison begleitend dazugeben
und ansonsten schauen, was passiert.
Was der Patient aber begleitend noch braucht, ist Physiotherapie.
Der braucht Physiotherapie, der braucht Schmerzmittel,
der hat Schmerzen, die müssen wir Schmerzmittel geben.
Er braucht Physiotherapie
und er braucht eine symptomatische Therapie
mit dem Acetylcholine-Receptor-Blocker
oder dem Cholenisterasehemmer, wie wir gesagt haben.
Und dem Mann ging es dann besser.
Was haben wir dann gemacht?
Wir haben den Mann dann wieder in die Neurologie geschickt,
nachdem der Diagnose feststand.
Wir haben den Neurologen hinzugerufen und gesagt,
guck mal, ihr habt da schon die Diagnose dick gemacht.
Das passt alles ja zu einer Myosthenie
und der wird auf Cortison besser.
Hat der Neurologen nur mit dem Kopf geschüttelt und gesagt,
ihr habt absolut recht.
Der Mann hat eine Myosthenie und eine schwere Form.
Also haben sie den übernommen,
um den wieder medikamentös gut einzustellen
und den Mann wieder fit zu machen.
Ich hoffe, das war so eine besondere Form
von allgemeinen Erkrankungen.
Es muss nicht immer Hahnwirksinfekt sein,
es muss auch nicht immer eine Lungenentzündung sein,
es muss auch nicht immer ein Tumor sein,
aber man muss als Arzt immer in alle Richtungen manchmal denken.
Man weiß nicht immer, was es ist.
Das war schwer.
Mit diesem Symptom eigentlich erwarte
auf Peralty syndrome.
Noch mal, welches Symptom bitte?
Peralty syndrome.
Über 50 Logra.
Abgenomen und Müdighat und Muskelschwache.
Ja.
Im Jahr 2017 erwarten wir auf
im Frühstzeitamtag
Muskelschwache.
Wie können wir fragen,
wann die Schwäche am stärksten ist?
Ob das morgens ist, ob das abends ist
oder zu welcher Tageszeit.
Zu welcher Tageszeit ist die Schwäche am stärksten?
Dann hätte er vielleicht gesagt morgens.
Aber der Mann war seit einem Jahr so schwer krank,
dass er ja am Anfang fast nicht richtig antworten konnte.
Ich habe mich mit dem an Anfang nicht unterhalten können.
Erst unter Cortison
kam er langsam wieder zu sich.
Im 100 Milligramm Cortison
ging es ihm wieder deutlich besser.
Er war geistig wieder da.
Er konnte antworten, er konnte wieder schlucken.
Nachdem er das Messdienon bekommen hat,
habe ich gesagt, so viel Cortison braucht er dann nicht.
Dann habe ich es reduziert, das war aber nicht so gut.
Dann ist er wieder schluckend.
Der Colonisteraser hat man nicht ausgereicht.
Er muss beides haben.
Am Anfang muss man Cortison, also immunosuppressive Therapie,
plus Messdienon geben,
damit die Symptomatik stabilisiert wird.
Ich denke, der Patient fühlt sich wieder auf der Welt.
Genau so ist es.
Er fühlt sich wieder auf der Welt.
Er fühlt sich wieder neugeboren,
mag wieder Kraft,
wenn er z.B. wieder mal etwas schluckem kann.
Und wenn die Mosclen vorsissementsaminglich am compensate
Ibuprofen hat deshalb gut gewirkt.
Das hatte auch von mir dreimal bekommen
und die Schmerzen waren gut kontrolliert.
Und ich denke, der wird mittlerweile auch wieder nach Hause gegangen sein.
Also, an Autoimmunerkrankungen auch denken.
Natürlich hätte es auch eine Sklerodermie sein können.
Natürlich hätte es auch die anderen Formen sein können.
Ein Morbus Fabri oder Feltisyndrom, das kann alles möglich auch sein.
Dass den Stoffwechselkrankheiten mag sein.
Aber ich habe mich jetzt auf die Mühe-Stin-Hin mal festgelegt,
weil ich gerade mit dem zu tun gehabt habe.
Nur, es gilt für alle, man muss in diese Richtung denken.
Und da die einfachste Methode ist,
einfach die antinukleären Antikörper
oder die doppel-DNS-Antikörper mal abnehmen
und dann mal schauen, ob da irgendwas Auffälliges da ist oder nicht.
Wenn nicht, muss man einen Schritt weitergehen
und sagen, was spricht dann dagegen,
wenn man einmal als etikulierende Rezeptantikörper abnimmt?
Bis wir die Ergebnisse dieser Labore bekommen haben,
wir können aufrecherchieren.
Richtig.
Dass das Dumme bei diesen Patienten war,
die Zeit von der Blutabnahme bis zur Vorlage der Ergebnis
hat drei Wochen gebraucht.
Das war eine ganz spezielle Untersuchung, die weggeschickt worden war.
Deswegen haben das die Neurologen gar nicht gesehen.
Wir haben durch Recherche,
einfach nachdem wir alles zusammengesucht haben,
fiel uns dann plötzlich dieser Wert in die Hände.
Und dann wussten wir, was los war.
Und es ist auch wichtig,
dass man sämtliche Vorbefunde sein wird dazu.
Sämtliche Arztberichte, Befunde von anderen Ärzten,
von anderen Krankenhäusern, alles zusammen so.
Und alles genau durchstudiert,
dann wird man manchmal fündig.
Ja.
Okay?
Okay.
Fragen?
Keine Fragen?
War einige nicht so einverstanden damit?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Aber wie können wir unter dem Landwirt Ethon-Centrum
unterschieden?
Den Unterschied zum Landwirt Ethon-Syndrom.
Was erwarten Sie denn jetzt?
Weshalb, wie kommen Sie jetzt auf Landwirt Ethon?
Ich habe nicht erinnert, aber
im Neurologie-Abteilung im Studium
hat unser Chef immer,
dass Sie sind ähnliche Symptome, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Wie gesagt, ganz spezifische Autorantikörper.
Landwirt Ethon, ich weiß nicht, ob der mit Acetylcholine-Rezeptorantikörper
Erhöhung einhergeht.
Da gibt es sicherlich feinere Unterschiede,
die man vielleicht noch neurologisch weiter verfeinern kann.
Aber in diesem Falle, Acetheareceptorantikörper,
war spezifisch für eine Myosthenie.
Das ist dann damit bewiesen.
Man kann sicherlich noch eine neurologische Untersuchung
mit einer Elektromyografie noch machen, eine EMG-Untersuchung.
Um zu schauen, ob da die Übertragung stimmt oder nicht,
die Nerven, Leitgeschwindigkeit usw.
Das kann man sicherlich noch machen.
Aber das ist eine neurologische Sache,
das ist keine internistische,
deswegen habe ich mich damit nicht beschäftigt.
Einfach. Danke schön.
Bitte.
Meine Frage.
Ja.
Also, wenn ich mich ein Pfandscherin erinnere,
wie es in ihr gröbes,
es zeigt sich aus 40 Jahren, 50 Jahre alt,
so 76 Jahre ist nicht so spät so eine.
Das ist ein Sonderfall.
Ja, es gibt immer wieder.
Also, so mittelaltere Menschen sagt man,
das ist überwiegend die Gruppe, die davon befallen ist.
Aber ich habe mich jetzt eines besseren Beleeren lassen.
Ein 76-Jähriger, der das auch hat,
zeigt, es ist nicht auszuschließen,
dass auch ältere Menschen etwas bekommen können.
Ja. Danke.
Söamet, ne Cam,
der Kopf am Ende ist, ist jetzt gut.
Aber,
ne, Türkische, wir konuşen,
das ist eine Konik, die du mir erinnert hast.
Also,
wie ich oder wie ein Fatma,
30 Jahre vor allem, waren wir in Meersen.
Aber wie viel Graves haben wir?
Wie viele haben wir nicht verstanden?
Meersen, Graves,
äh,
es ist nicht möglich, dass wir ein ungewöhnliches Ärzte haben.
Wir haben eine Art, die 76 Jahre alt ist,
die wir haben, die wir geben,
nichts zu geben.
Ich weiß nicht, wie meine Frau das gemacht hat.
Ich denke, dass ich die
Das ist ein wichtiges Thema.
Es ist so, dass es in solchen Situationen wie eine Direktive
die Beherrung, die Rapporte, die alle zusammenführen.
Es wird Zeit.
Wenn du die Stunden mit deinem Telefon hinstellen,
dann holst du sie dort, holst du sie dort, holst du sie dort.
Dann holst du sie dort, holst du sie dort, holst du sie dort.
Du willst sie dort, holst sie dort, holst sie dort.
Du willst sie dort, holst sie dort.